on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I play some organized censored coming up
on tonight's program is not a celebrity
he's a get him out of here Matt Hancock
pocketing 400 000 pounds to go to
Australia and eat kangaroo testicles
with a record recession looming in
Britain it's time for him to tooth in
the jungle and his job
Star Wars Legend be with me Mark Hamill
that's Luke Skywalker of course to talk
about his latest Battle of good over
evil to defeat Vladimir Putin in Ukraine
and he played Hitler but of course he's
not a Nazi acting Legend Stephen burkov
well talk to me about the outcry of a
non-disabled actors playing disabled
roles great actors playing gay roles and
now non-jewish actors playing Jewish
rocks
[Music]
live from London this is Piers Morgan
today was another very bad very serious
day for this country the bank of England
raised interest rates by 0.75 percent
the highest rate hike for over 30 years
since the infamous black Wednesday and
it warned our economy could continue to
shrink until 2024 in the worst recession
it says for a century well thanks to the
disastrous mini budget that cost hapless
Liz truss her job as prime minister
after just 44 diabolical days in office
Britain is now facing severe Financial
pain for maybe two more years and it
could get a lot worse a lot quicker in
two weeks new prime minister issue
sooner can Chancellor Jeremy Hunt will
be forced to increase taxes and slash
public spending which is pretty much the
worst possible cocktail to pour into the
bonfire of a shrinking economy millions
of britons already reading from
crippling rises in food and energy
prices will now see their mortgages
rocket too and house prices are put into
the crash by up to 30 percent next year
destroying the value of homes that are
costing ever more to pay for it's a
perfect storm of hell and the victims
and there'll be many of them will need
all the help they can get from their
members of parliament that they elected
to serve them but where will these MPS
be as the crisis escalates
well one of them Matt Hancock will be in
Australia 10 000 miles from its
constituency in West Suffolk taking part
in the reality TV show I'm a celebrity
get me out of here
it's already spot outraged they're
continuing to receive his 84 000 pound
salary as an MP while speaking on the
other side of the world munching as I
said earlier on kangaroo testicles and
humiliating challenges normally reserved
for fading zedless celebrities he's not
a celebrity
but now it's emerged that Hancock's been
paid a staggering 400 000 pounds for his
shameful little self-promoting Jolly to
the other side of the world one of the
highest sums ever paid to any contestant
in the show's history he told the Sun
newspaper he wasn't doing it for the
money but that's the cynical lie as all
the lies he told us Health secretary and
his decision to deserve his duty at this
dark half of the country which he says
he's doing for the right reasons but
he's not
of course Matt Hancock's doing this for
the money that's why he turned down the
invitation twice this summer to do I'm a
celebrity until the check was big enough
and what exactly has Mr Hancock done to
earn this massive payday well he became
Britain's Health secretary just before
the covert pandemic began and he was a
total disaster failing on everything
from testing and PPE
to making elderly people from hospitals
go back into Care Homes without testing
them for the virus and that turned the
Care Homes into death traps his
abjecting competence is one of the main
reasons the UK suffered the worst death
toll of any European country and to
compound his deadly ineptitude he then
got caught breaking his own Draconian
lockdown Rules by conducting an affair
with an aid inside government buildings
and was forced to resign
the normal price such a double whammy of
disgrace should have been a long and
preferably permanent period away from
any form of public office but instead
Hancock remains in public office but
without doing any public duties he's
gone off to rake it in not just from I'm
a celebrity but he's also signed up for
channel 4's SAS who does win series he's
even found time to write a volume of
diaries about his calamitous handling of
the pandemic quite literally Penning
blood Money
all was continuing to be an MP with his
salary being paid by the British people
who many of them are facing Financial
ruin
clear this is an absolute disgrace
Hancock is a Shameless sleazeball who's
betraying his constituents his party and
his country and he should be deselected
as an MP as a matter of urgency
well joining me now is the former Royal
Butler I'm a celebrity runner-up for
Barrel former conservative MP Louise
mench and in the studio palliative care
Dr Rachel Clark well welcome to all of
you Rachel we never met but we had a lot
of discussions during the pandemic When
I Was a Good Morning Britain and things
got very heated you were a very powerful
Advocate I felt for the Health Service
about what was going on what is your
reaction to Matt Hancock who was the
health secretary over a disastrous
handling of this pandemic for so many
months at the start now becoming this
highly paid reality TV style yeah
I didn't think my opinion of that man
could sink any lower but honestly Matt
Hancock's shamelessness it knows no
bounds he's not a celebrity he's a
failed Health secretary he was forced
out of office in disgrace after having
apparently enough free time in the
biggest Public Health crisis facing the
world to conduct an extra marital Affair
breaking his own lockdown rules in the
process and time and again he would
stand there in front of the cameras
lying to all our faces he would say
there were no problems with PPE when I
had nurses in my Hospital dying of covid
because they didn't get the right PPE he
would say he had he used the phrase I've
thrown a protective ring around Care
Homes that's a lie utter lie something
like 40 000 people died in that first
wave in Care Homes because he oversaw
and authorized sending people back
without testing and and so now our after
all of that serial incompetence and
cereal lying about his incompetence for
him now to stand up pocket four hundred
thousand pounds incidentally that's two
pounds for every one of the 200 000
people who have died of covid
um through this pandemic for him to
pocket that money and actually try to
pretend that he's doing this in the
public interest I find breathtaking he
said that he is doing this because it's
important for politicians to go where
the people are as though somehow eating
a plate of kangaroo anuses in Australia
is an act of Public Service it's just
disgusting you know what he should be
doing is facing the music for what
happened on the pandemic I we found a
clip of me challenging him this is after
the government spent eight months
avoiding me and Susanna Reid on Good
Morning Britain they came back after
boycott and the first guess back was
Matt Hancock and he got quite heated
let's take a look
uh it then turned out that Care Homes
far from having the ringer protection
which you've been boasting about ever
since we actually sent thousands of
elderly people out of hospitals back
into Care Homes without testing them for
covid so a new epidemic was started
failing Health secretary I say this with
respect to you but I say it's respect
for it I don't I don't underappreciate
how difficult a job this is but I also
know it's what you signed up for we have
had a constant series of failures and
u-turns throughout this year I mean are
you prepared to admit to any mistakes of
the of the charge sheet I read out
uh sure of course we've made uh mistakes
absolutely no he should be facing the
music on this in a tribunal an inquiry
and any other official bodies that are
coming down the track about what
happened in this country and that
particularly in that first wave of the
pandemic when we were so woefully
underprepared remember Matt Hancock at
the start of the pandemic stood up in
the House of Commons in January in 2020
and he assured us that we were fully
prepared for what was to come and it
turned out we couldn't have been less
prepared with no testing system no
personal protective equipment that's why
so many people died he worked in in our
health system
the borders were left wide open for
everyone to bring the virus in and so on
and so on on every single metric in that
first six months it was a total disaster
and the idea that he's not going to
profit massively from a book about his
failures in the pandemic and now become
a reality TV star making hundreds of
thousands of pounds as a celebrity from
his failure and his infamy as someone
who had to quit his job or be fired over
illicit Affair breaking his own lockdown
rules it's beyond belief now some people
despite all this are prepared to defend
him Louise Mensch joins me from New York
uh often defends indefensible on this
program uh normally finds out belatedly
that I'm right all along uh also joined
by Paul Burrell uh welcome to you as
well Paul I'll come to you in a moment
Louise Mensch how on Earth do you defend
this when we've just just been told by
the bank of England that we're facing
the worst recession in the hundred years
this man is a highly paid Member of
Parliament who has a constituency see of
people who are going to desperately need
his help he's 10 000 miles away eating
kangaroo bollocks what's going on
well I think maybe he thought that was a
more hospitable environment for him than
the House of Commons and by the way I
told you Rishi sunak would be a disaster
and so it is proving I don't defend Matt
Hancock what he's doing he shouldn't be
doing it and for him to go out and say
it's not about the money it's just
taking people for fools quite frankly
um but that said I think it's the least
important thing for the conservative
party to be faffing around taking the
whip away from him they didn't take it
away from Nadine Doris that's just
hypocrisy and I think what she's still
like is using this entire Affair to
distract from the fact that he's got a
criminal as Home Secretary that's what's
really important not that Matt Hancock
is on his way out the door to be honest
with you and is lining his pockets on
the way out yeah
I don't agree as long as he remains A
Member of Parliament his salary is paid
for by the British taxpayer the British
taxpayers in their millions are facing
the worst cost living crisis in living
memory and many of them will need their
MPS help in their constituency it's an
absolute abrogation of his duty to Jet
off the other side of the world and take
part in some dumb reality show
well perhaps it's time for the House of
Commons to change the rules so that MPS
can't do this he's not the first and he
won't be the last there was that um Doug
Dale I think she is her name is the SMP
MP who did it as well but the fact is
right now the rules protect MPS who want
to go away and line their pockets with a
little bit of mean 400 000 pounds is a
hell of a lot of money it's pretty clear
to me that Matt Hancock isn't going to
stand again and this isn't the only
project that he's doing should he be
doing it absolutely not is the
government use it to distract from the
Home Secretary being a criminal leaker
who's worse than a rusty colander in my
opinion yes they are but if you ask me
if I defend Matt Hancock making this
choice I say I definitely don't when I
was an MP they offered me a large amount
of money to go and do that show and I
turned them down I wasn't a government
celebrity I I didn't think it was
appropriate at all but I think I might
be the only MP that's ever said no to
that amount of cash right I mean this is
the thing Paul Burrell isn't it he's
obviously we know he's getting divorced
or his divorce now I can't keep up with
his his Shenanigans but um we know he
probably needs the money uh we know that
he is probably got no way back to
Frontline politics he was humiliated by
Richie sunac uh last week in a really
cringe-making video when he's blanked
him so there's no way back for him at
high level so he's banking the cash my
point I mean you've been in I'm a
celebrity we're going to see him laid
bare yes uh probably at his worst aren't
we because they they'll know that's what
the British public will want to see him
ritually humiliated what's it like in
that jungle is there any escape from the
glare of the cameras
no
there's no hiding once you're in the
jungle clearing the Great British public
will decide themselves if they like Matt
Hancock or not and my prediction is they
won't I don't think Matt Hancock will do
himself any any Justice by doing I'm
excited to get you out of here because
You Can't Hide You can't lie you
yourself
um you're literally
um laid bare and anything and everything
he does will be recorded and I think the
Great British public would love to see
our health secretary swigging back a
cockroach smoothie it'll make great
television but he won't do him any good
I mean I would love to see him
humiliated no question but I just and I
keep thinking back to the pandemic and I
keep thinking of all the families who
couldn't go and see their dying loved
ones they couldn't have weddings
funerals they couldn't have christening
they couldn't do any of these things
your sacrifice is made by the public
yeah well he's and we're immeasurably
worsened by Matt Hancock's incompetence
yeah and then he brazenly broke his own
lockdown rules to have an affair and has
to be fired from his job and now he
seems to be making all this profit from
books from TV shows off the back of
ignominium disgrace
it's an incredible fee to pay someone to
sit in the jungle and eat a kangaroo's
penis isn't it but you know somebody's
paying this amount of money to humiliate
him really and I thought that Parliament
was still sitting I thought his job was
to sit in Parliament on behalf of his
constituents and ask them what they
think they can't be too happy
no I mean this is the point really isn't
it um bring Rachel back in I mean I just
if I'm if I'm a West Suffolk constituent
watching this go down this guy is
already you know been the subject of
national hatred over a lot of the
terrible mistakes he made in the
pandemic then National ridicule for the
affair which broke his own rules which
is why he had to go now they're going to
see him be humiliated doing the most
cringe-making things in a jungle in
Australia while they're all suffering
financial hardship there's got to be a
Tipping Point isn't it just enough
absolutely I mean
he obviously thinks he's a celebrity he
obviously thinks he's going to win the
British public over that the public that
I saw in the NHS every day of that
pandemic was the absolute best of
Britain people being decent courageous
frightened but putting on a brave face
sacrificing over and over again to help
each other that's what most people did
they rolled up their sleeves they tried
their best he wasn't so much rolling up
his sleeves as far as I can tell as
groping the bottom of the woman with
whom he was having his affair pretty
sleazy stuff and and now he's not a
celebrity he's a grubby little man who's
making blood money off the notoriety
that was rightly heated yeah I totally
agree and and and I just think his ego's
writing checks that his morals can't
cash it's an absolute disgrace and is it
so wrong and is it so old-fashioned to
want politicians who have a sense of
Public Service I you rightly say the pub
of countries going into crisis
politicians should be putting their
constituents first absolutely he's
bankrolling a nest egg thing and by the
way he's been paid 86 000 pounds to
serve his constituents and he'll be away
for a month so it's unbelievable
um the team did a little mashup of Matt
Hancock's uh I don't know what you call
this really let's just play it and you
can all laugh at him
[Music]
you're quite emotional about that well
it's just
[Music]
is this your rally cry to the nation to
have a caramel waffle to get you going
if you like your caramel waffle have a
caramel waffle just don't have too many
and do a bit of exercise get out there
and get your vaccine
foreign
buffoon an absolute buffoon but I think
there's a lot of people who won't be
laughing about this who will be as angry
as I am as you are Rachel and I think as
everybody else will be I think it's
completely shameful anyway thank you for
joining me it's good to finally meet you
pleasure Louise thank you for joining me
from New York uh Paul always good to
talk to you appreciate you joining the
program thank you all very much uh we'll
still still to come tonight was it wrong
to cast a non-jewish act in this case
Anthony Hopkins as a Jewish immigrant
Bond star Stephen berkoff gives me his
team he must play a Nazi and from taking
on Darth Vader to help him defeat the
biggest villain on planet Earth Mark
Hamill Luke Skywalker himself will be
willing to talk about his battle with
Vladimir Putin on behalf of the
Ukrainian people
that'll be coming next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook guest has been
a household name for decades after
landing his first break as Luke
Skywalker in Star Wars he was catapulted
into worldwide Fame where he's resided
ever since there's more to Mark Hamill
than his on-screen triumphs he's been a
Force for good for the people of Ukraine
president zielinski personally appointed
him Ambassador for the army of drones to
help fight Putin so before I asked him
about switching from taking on Darth
Vader to help him defeat the biggest
villain on planet Earth and his rumored
love triangle with Carrie Fisher and
Harrison Ford surely not let's be
reminded of his iconic Star Wars role as
Luke Skywalker
ready for a stormtrooper
Skywalker I'm here to rescue
I am the father
now well I guess you don't know
everything about women yet
[Music]
[Music]
take your fathers please set my side
I'll never turn to the dark side
well Mark Hamill uh joins me now mark
thank you so much for joining the
program
thanks for having me I want to start
with a dramatic confession
um because I know that you were
complaining in a recent interview that
you always have to talk about Star Wars
in interviews I can probably make that
easier for you because I I have never
watched any of the Star Wars movies
well that's
Viva La difference you know I'm glad I'm
glad people don't all like the same
things it'd be very boring I've got to
say that notwithstanding that my eldest
son discovered that you were on tonight
I don't think I've ever known him more
excited he's nearly 30. he has one of
those things that you wave around I know
in the movies the the lightsaber
Lifesavers
um and he is so incredibly excited about
this so I might at the end just ask you
to send him the force or or whatever it
is but you'll be pleased to know I'm
gonna Focus right now on uh something
much dearer to my heart which is Ukraine
I went to Ukraine uh back in July and I
went to see President zielinski
interviewed him and his wife the first
lady and I was struck by a lot of things
about them I think they're a remarkable
couple and he's a remarkable leader in
this incredibly difficult time
um but I also was struck by something
you said about about this when you spoke
to him on zoom and you're reflecting on
it afterwards but he was a guy who was
an actor like you you know he was a guy
just basically running a TV production
company taking part as a comedic actor
and then he he ends up playing somebody
who randomly runs for president uh in a
comedy and then he ultimately runs for
president
he becomes president and within a year
he's plunged into the first major war in
Europe since the second world war it's
an extraordinary story isn't it as
someone who's obviously an actor like
him what do you make of it
it really it it really is and uh uh I I
first became aware of him during the
first impeachment trial and did my
research and like you say he started out
as an actor life imitates art he wound
up doing a series called servant of the
people which I also watched he's an
inspirational leader and the way the
Ukrainian people have come together in
in these in these terrible times I mean
like you say we've never seen a
sovereign nation invaded uh by a hostile
foreign Nation since World War II no
you've got involved in a really
brilliant campaign I think which is
about the use of drones to monitor the
two and a half thousand kilometers front
line in Ukraine
um it's called United 24 and the way it
works as I'm mistaken is that people
like yourself have been raising money
and awareness for this and then the
drones are sent to Ukraine for them to
use and in fact you'd have been directly
responsible for over 500 drones now
being sent over to Ukraine and they are
incredibly useful because they are
basically the eyes and ears for the
Ukrainian people in detecting missiles
and so on exactly
exactly in in a simple statement Ukraine
needs drones drones Define War outcomes
and they're able to monitor the Border
uh and protect both civilians and their
soldiers so what surprised me was not
only were they interested in in
fundraising but if you have a drone I
was unaware that this is a popular Hobby
and people that are hobbyists that are
focused on drones they have uh multiple
drones they say oh well that's two years
ago that's the old model I've got the
updated version and Ukraine can use even
the most simplistic drones they don't
fly very far but like you say they're
the eyes in the sky and it's really
crucial now that Russia is struggling on
the Battle Front they've been attacking
behind the battlefield
bombing civilian infrastructure schools
playgrounds it's really terrible yeah
and not to mention the fact that for the
last four weeks uh the large portions of
Ukraine have no water right there's
power outages so anything that can be
done to to help is greatly greatly
appreciated when you spoke to president
zielinski in this Zoom conversation I
know that Star Wars did come up and of
course the parallel I think that you
both realize which is pretty pretty
Stark actually is that the themes of the
Star Wars movies were always about good
taking on evil and good ultimately
triumphing here you have a really I
think a pretty clear-cut example of good
people of Ukraine being illegally
invaded by bad people Vladimir Putin and
his Russian military how do you think
this ends I mean are we going to be in a
position where like in a movie good will
ultimately Triumph or is it more is it
going to be more difficult than that
well it's impossible to say I mean
everyone expected Ukraine to just roll
over and give up instead they've mounted
this
ferocious resistance uh and they're
making great strides I I pray that uh
Putin finds some face-saving event to
say okay I've accomplished what I wanted
and we're pulling out because uh he's
been humiliated uh uh uh and and that's
not good for someone
as aggressive as he is right so um I I
don't know it's just terrible over 115
countries now have donated not just to
Army of drones but you know uh uh
zielinski appointed various ambassadors
I know Lee Schreiber is in charge of one
aspect Barbra Streisand another aspect
uh Imagine Dragons the musical group and
they there are all
have their separate responsibilities
mind being the army of drones well I
think I think it's I'm just I think it's
brilliant honestly I think when I was
there the resilience of that of the
people Ukraine was incredibly palpable
they don't want to give Putin an inch
and they are desperate for support and
help from the rest of us in the west and
I think they'll be hugely appreciative
as I know zielinski was about what
you've been doing and using your profile
for doing that so um you know really
well done and keep up that great work
and we'll certainly direct people from
this show to to work out how they can
get involved too I want to just pivot
slightly too can I mention the yes if I
could can I mention the website really
quick it's you two for
u24.gov which is
gov.ua forward slash dronation right
u24.gov dot UA forward slash
d-r-o-n-a-t-i-o-n well I will be able to
I will set and I will tweet that to my 8
million Twitter followers which I passed
this morning Mark uh now I've actually
had a little Spurt of followers in the
last couple of weeks you've had the
opposite and you're blaming Elon Musk
yeah
no I'm not I I just stated the fact that
I lost over 6 000 in the first three
days it was weird then I gained them
back and then some and now I've fallen
back another ten thousand I'm not
blaming anybody I just don't understand
what's going on how many do you have
spots how many photos you have
I have five point
two and I just got over 5.3 and then I
lost and went back to 5.2 but you know
it's every Everything's Relative you
know when I start thinking wow I've got
five million followers and you find out
like Taylor Swift has 180 million or
something so I mean I've got to say I'm
big I'm quietly pleased I've got three
million more than Luke Skywalker
well there you go
congratulations
maybe if you watch the movie if you
watch the movies you'll go up even
higher you know what I am gonna I'm
going to my son has been on and on at me
about I can't tell you what a massive
fan is
um what do you think about Elon Musk
wanting to charge People Like Us uh to
have to keep our Blue Tick are you going
to pay him his eight dollars a month
no you know it reminds me they I got
contacted by the who's who people and
they wanted me to be in Who's Who and
then when I found out there was a 250
fee I said what are they crazy if I'm
really somebody they'll put me in
without the fee so I didn't pay it I
don't know whether I'm in it or not but
I think that's ridiculous I don't
understand I mean uh
when I went on Twitter they just gave me
that check and I guess it's just to
authenticate that it's really you but uh
I've been on Twitter for so long now I
don't think I'll miss it
I think people know what it finds your
way um what is the best or worst thing
about being Luke Skywalker one of the
all-time iconic movie roles best and
worst
well um
one of the best things is that
people feel like they know you so
wherever I go
uh people talk about how the those films
affected their lives whether it got them
through a parent's illness or uh you
know they met their future spouse
at a screening I mean people relate it
in such personal ways it it means a lot
I don't know what the worst thing is I
guess it's because uh you know when I do
something and it's over I just let it go
and
I have these kids that come up to me and
not just kids you know adults as well
that know so much more about it than I
do because I don't watch them over and
over I watch them when they came out and
I don't watch them again so they know
details that I I don't know what they're
talking about and he says is there any
Prospect of Luke raising his lightsaber
again or is it all over
oh it's over
[Laughter]
really is over Mark if you could just do
me one favor and make me father of the
year could you just stare down the
barrel of the camera and say Spencer
Morgan May the force be with you
Spencer Morgan the force will be with
you always
that's absolutely fantastic uh Mark
Hamill what a pleasure to have you on
the program thank you so much
thanks for having me Pierce and keep up
the great work in Ukraine it's it's a
hugely appreciated by by them all that I
know and very important work thank you
very much all the left
well still to come uh he told me on this
show but he conquered his fear of dying
once he entered politics and today it
was almost put to the test we'll discuss
the attempted assassination of Imran
Khan today in Pakistan be coming up the
mega Stars just keep coming on
uncensored Stephen burkov will join me
next should only Jewish people play Jews
in movies
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook and uncensor
there have been outcries and
non-disabled actors playing disabled
roles straight actors playing gay roles
and now there's criticism of non-jewish
actors playing Jewish roles the director
of a new film Armageddon time has been
forced to defend his use of actors who
are not Jewish including Anthony Hopkins
betraying members of a Jewish immigrant
family so should Hollywood be more
authentic with his representation or
should actors be allowed to do what it
says on their team which is act well I'm
joined by acting Legend James Bond
octopussy Legend of course Stephen
burkhoff and I'm joined also by talk to
the contributors Esther to Cracker and
Paula Roan Adrian uh Stephen Burke of
wonderful to have on the program thank
you very much
oh it's a pleasure Pierce thank you for
having me I've been on this this uh
issue for quite a quite a while because
I personally my middle son's an actor
and I just think actors should be
allowed to act and that the moment you
start saying well only people can play
actual like you know only disabled
people can play disabled roles only gay
people can play gay roles and so on I
think you just destroy the whole purpose
of acting am I am I wrong
oh you're totally right I totally
absolutely agree with you I think is
about it's not only impersonation a
mimicry it's also about bringing to life
those other people that maybe not get
the opportunity to make their case to
tell their stories and to move people so
I think it's very very good that actors
play anything that's their job as you
Whitely say that's on the 10 and you act
on the other hand there's another side
to it
now that side if I have a moment or two
is a different kind of acting which is
attracting which is based on plays
stories histories based on real events
and we had some for Jews particularly in
this case as we're talking about Jews
these really events happened in Europe
over the last over a thousand years of
the most horrible uh appalling terrible
terrifying painful murderous uh
uh experience at the same particular
race could have so these Horrors that
we've experienced over a thousands of
years starting in England in 1290 when
they were kicked out of England and go
to Spain where they had to suffer from
the Christian churches in position and
burning of all sorts of hours like that
then to France where they had you know
where was Colonel Dreyfus being
sentenced as being a traitor which
affected the whole Jews of France and
the French also
the opportunity to pull out the Jews
from their cities and then bung them
into the German concentration camp so
they've had then the Communists to deal
with like Stalin and so the Jews are
suffered are enormous iniquities so when
the drama comes when out of this comes
the histories and the dramas and the
place and the music and
the Jews may feel they'd like to be part
of this to tell their own story so after
all these events that have happened
they may feel to a certain extent rather
sensitive when they read of the Uno of a
very Charming wonderful white Christian
someone like Anthony Hopkins a nice
blue-eyed Welshman playing uh
to a certain extent I understand that
very well
it's interesting because you've painted
a sort of good argument on both sides
there so do you have some sympathy with
the argument that maybe the two sides
you see yeah no I I understand I thought
yeah I thought you you argued both like
a good lawyer you argue both cases
rather well both sides of it but I
wonder in the end which side would you
come down on in the sense that would it
would it have been right not to have
cast Anthony Hopkins should they given
this was about Jewish Heritage in this
film should they have actually opted for
Jewish actors of whom there are
obviously very many including yourself
well I think they they should have uh
for my opinion uh taken a little bit of
time to search out the Jewish actor no
matter how brilliant Anthony Hopkins is
and he's a wonderful character actor and
a brilliant mimic but maybe to search
our summer because his actual skill and
the genius of Hopkins could even to a
certain extent work against the story
because he is now much more famous than
the character he's playing obviously so
you know we don't know anything about
the character he's playing but we know
so much about Hopkins so I think they
should have maybe just had a look around
and searched out uh Jewish actors
because as I say the history of Europe
in the last thousand or more years has
become
um you know Legends has become like a
second Bible but let me ask you I mean
let me ask you as a you know I I I'm
thinking about what you're saying and
you're making very good points and I can
understand why people feel this way
about it but when you draw the line
because once you start saying right only
Jewish actors can play important Jewish
roles do you then extrapolate that out
and say only only gay men can play
famous gay people in history for example
you know disabled people we've saw
obviously people like uh Tom Cruise play
a disabled role in Born the 4th of July
we saw Tom Hanks you know when he'd come
to aid for example in Philadelphia
shining a massive light on that case my
argument's always been massive movie
stars if they act well consign a
massively bigger light sometimes on his
shoes simply by their star power than
just taking somebody of less star
wattage and therefore if your aim is to
get as many people to watch these things
as possible and raise awareness of the
issues at stage aren't you better off
just going with the best actors
regardless of their background
yes I mean I totally agree with you but
in this particular case uh the situation
is rather unusual and rather unique yeah
because the suffering has been turned
into now mythology and it's been turned
into Legend and somehow this no no say
somehow these people The Descendants
and
their heirs and their fellow you know
the
um
beings in blood
may be that much more sensitive to how
these Legends are being taken although
as you say we have Tom Hanks blame the
gay people and they can bring a lot more
light and a lot more attention to their
cause but this is a rather unusual
situation
you is a Jewish man you played a Nazi
famously for example yes I mean if you
if you yes I played Adolf Hitler yes so
yeah so you played the most infamous
Nazi of them all Adolf Hitler is that
appropriate yes is it appropriate for a
Jewish actor to play Adolf Hitler
absolutely because this will make him
turn in his grave and I think this is
what Dan Curtis who was the famous
producer said I mean as I was doing
Adolf and I'd enjoy doing the part it
was an amazing part but he's also a kind
of a such an ugly despicable sordid and
digital
evil and villain that they wanted a good
actor who could project that who had the
power to project Hitler and at the time
I was the one he looked at loads and
loads of actors and those one but he's
he's an evil villain I don't think is
going to affect
any narcissist or make them weep that's
one of their own kind wasn't chosen but
I think I think you're right it would
have annoyed him enormously which is the
exact reason to do it before I let you
go absolutely you were one of the Great
Bond villains uh there's a big debate
going on about who should replace Daniel
Craig some people on the feminist arm of
life would like to see a woman replace
Daniel Craig as James Bond what are your
very brief reaction to that idea
well of course it's an appalling idea we
must give credit to the what gender
he is right for a role you can't just
say well because of ignore it's more
political correct now we should look at
women to play or almost anything now
they can do you know they can do James
Bond they'll end up playing Muhammad Ali
but maybe let's be respectful to a
certain extent to the author and that's
what he created his uh his paintbrush
was limited his canvas was rather was
limited this was the kind of man he
idealized as the tough match over is he
getting is he getting emasculated bonds
though Stephen I mean I just can't now
he starts crying he's in touch with his
sensitive side and all this kind of
nonsense he's not allowed to go near
women anymore he can't smoke he can't
drink he's like are we basically
neutering Bond shouldn't we just go back
now to how he used to be I would
probably yes unfortunately probably we
are rather I think that's the nature of
the how
you know the art imitates life and his
life will be coming much more
politically correct about not doing
anything they can hurt anyone even the
fly and so now we're kind of a
kind of impersonating this in films so
people didn't really see them pick up a
cigarette or or you know behind you they
can drink you can drink fish
final question and I want a one word or
two word answer who
c b James Bond next
but to tell you the truth Benedict
Cumberbatch ah great I say because he
has the most wonderful voice yes and we
want to see bond with an authority and
that metallic power because as Oscar
Wilde said a man who controls the dinner
table can control the world and but it
was tired of seeing him doing wheelies
and cars and things let him Inspire yeah
he's got a bit of that old-fashioned
English challenge little twinkle in his
eye I think it's even great call on on
Cumberbatch great to talk to you I've
got to leave you there thank you very
much indeed
P.S it's been a pleasure thank you very
much all the best great to have you
the great Stephen Burke well next
tonight I'll be discussing uh the
Scandal that's killed Christmas I'll
give you a clue it's about a chocolate
bar called Bounty the greatest of all
chocolate bars currently being
eradicated at the altar of political
correctness
the back after the break
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh if you missed
the big breaking news earlier I passed 8
million followers on Twitter today so if
you're not following me what's the
matter with you yes there we go
is Morgan do you know what to do just
press follow and get those numbers even
higher just to annoy everybody
um another more serious note today I
want to send my very best wishes to
someone I interviewed a few months ago
on the program Imran Khan the former
prime minister of Pakistan who was the
subject of an assassination attempt
today he was hit uh several times uh
point-blank range he fortunately
survived we think with leg injuries and
he is okay is the word from Pakistan I
actually spoke to him about the threat
of being assassinated when he came on
the program
where there's a genuine threat against
you of assassination do you feel fear
when I entered politics I actually had
conquered my fear of dying otherwise I
would not have entered politics because
I came in to stand up against the entire
status quo I came came to fight
corruption I thought it wouldn't succeed
you know for some reason I thought that
it's not possible that you know the
conspiracy was to replace me I have no
fear of dying
well fortunately he he wasn't killed
today but he could have been and of
course you'll remember Benazir Bhutto
who was assassinated it's a constant
concern I think for any leaders in
Pakistan and we wish him all the very
best and of course his family uh as well
he's got some sons who would have been
I'm sure very disturbed by what happened
today and they'll be very relieved he's
okay as we all are on the program
um
the break about this absolutely shocking
development where Mars for reasons best
known to themselves did a survey about
their celebration boxes which we all get
at Christmas right get one of these at
Christmas share it out with the family
we all dive in I do this Milky Way no
thanks Mars Bar no thanks Marathon not
interested right and I keep digging
Snickers are they called now uh you know
galaxies no no no no no no and there's
only one thing I'm ever looking for and
it's the Bounty bars I love Bounty I
have to say I like the dark Bounty
rather than the milk juggle ones not as
sweet but it's my favorite chocolate and
they're now removing it because 37 of
something in the British public said
they didn't like them in the box
that's a lack of taste this is going to
ruin Christmas for me if you can't get
him in the Box okay so two things arise
after this the first is quite a serious
one so as a black female oh dear God I
will no longer tolerate a disgusting
racist slurs
from a bounty chocolate I'll educate you
on you on that later are you serious
absolutely you've never heard that's
disgusting racism it's about racism
that's the first thing I won't miss that
anymore and the second reason is
they're not very nice and we all know
that is completely nonsense
many times and I wasn't offended because
I actually like a bounties and she uses
a racist oh yeah that's like my nickname
I've never heard that before but I have
all these boundaries so the references
am I allowed to say what the reference
is so the reference is is that you are
black on the outside and then white on
the inside which doesn't even make sense
I was just gonna say because I've got
somebody to explain to me what that
actually means so is it because of the
way I speak or is it because
maybe to my own Chagrin I've never heard
this but I've never heard this before
yeah it's not similar
right but yeah can't we really keep
chocolate bars out of the race debate
seriously well they're very personal
they're very personal what do you mean
the slurs no chocolate bars they're very
personal I mean like look at how upset
you're getting my idea of a perfect
celebration you're not gonna like it
what you just said now I feel bad about
it right but this is my idea of a
perfect celebration box which Mars
should be doing but there should be more
games exclusively Bounty bar what we
have here is a multicultural World
um what we have here no we have here
it's hell on Earth no we have a bunch of
things right so by your argument if
we're going to roll that out you can't
have any of these because they're all
chocolate right which in itself can be
used as a racist term so once you play
the race car with chocolates it's all
over isn't it exactly isn't it I've
never been I've never been called so
there's lots of Milky Way then I don't
know
there should only be three chocolates in
celebrations Bounty Snickers um and Twix
I just think look sometimes I can bear a
Snickers occasionally a Mars bar
definitely not the Milky the Milky
lights yeah it's awful not interested
right any of those but most of it is
inedible Tosh right but these little
Beauties what does a bounty do for you a
Snickers it gives you energy
it genuinely gives me it's like a
tropical feel every Christmas I like to
do this it takes you back to Barbados
you take a bounty
[Music]
I mean you're literally on the beach in
Mexico but now you're making me feel
like a racist freak
that's true now I feel terrible they're
delicious
trains are bouncing look that's all
we've got time for
I feel terrible okay we're not attentive
good night
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]